I foresee this movie causing lots of
awkward conversations with parents with
their children afterwards about where
babies really come from the odd life of
Timothy green is this new Disney movie
it stars this little kid CJ Adams
Jennifer Garner and Joel Edgerton it's
about these two parents who really want
a kid so bad in their doctor tells them
it's not gonna happen so they decide to
take every little thing that they want
in a kid write it down in a notebook on
a piece of paper and then put it in a
box and bury it in their garden outside
that night a rainstorm happens in the
middle of a drought and the child
miraculously is born from the dirt and
now they have a kid but it's strange
because the kid has leaves on his legs
he obviously does not fit in he's a
little strange he has all the little
qualities they wrote on those papers
they love him they have a kid but they
don't really understand how to make him
fit in because he came from the garden
seeing the trailers for this movie I was
really dreading going to this movie
because it just looks like this Hallmark
TV special laughs happy sappy
sentimentality you know it just it looks
really bad and I will say this movie
actually isn't awful it's not an awful
movie the trailers do make it out to
look like some you know Disney Channel
original movie and in some ways it is
but the trailers are definitely doing it
a little bit of injustice it's not a
terrible movie it's not really a good
movie though either I gotta be honest
and it's funny because I mentioned this
in my intro but when I was driving home
I was really thinking like young kids
are they gonna be really confused by
this movie and like look at their dad
and go dad
I was wondering did I come from the
ground uh
yes son yes you did mm-hmm
because Billy said I come from vagina
and penis yes that too I just have a
feeling it's gonna cause a lot of those
birds and bees discussions I know it's
going to it at least for a few kids it's
got to happen I will say this the kid in
this movie CJ Adams he's actually pretty
good and that's saying a lot for me cuz
I'm usually annoyed with kids and movies
and not he didn't bother me yes pretty
much his entire performance revolves
around him being extremely cute he
actually wasn't annoying in this movie
he actually did an okay job he's from
Dan in real life as well and he did a
pretty good job in that movie too I'm
not really a fan of Jennifer guard
I never really I I don't know I think
she's I just don't know actually what it
is I'm just not really a fan of hers she
was okay in the film she was fine
I thought joel edgerton did a great job
I thought out of the two parents that he
really shined in this movie I thought he
did a very good job in this movie and
it's not just because he's a man and I'm
a man and I relate to him because he's a
man and we're both men I just thought he
gave a good performance in the film and
I thought it was a bright spot of this
movie problems with this movie are is
that it is incredibly cliched it is it
really honestly is like every little
thing happens and yeah basically every
two minutes of this movie the filmmakers
kind of want you to go oh this is just
an incredibly sappy film it really is
very very sentimental and that's not
always a bad thing but this movie is
drenched in it it's it's it's reeking of
just it's so beautiful and cute oh my
god you can see like a family going to
it and a little kid just really enjoying
and they're leaving and they're happy in
fact I actually saw quite a bit of kids
that leaving this movie and they were
actually like hopping like they were
looks so excited I think my biggest plus
I can say with this movie without
spoiling anything I'm trying to figure
out how to say it without spot I thought
it was impressive it impressed me the
direction the film took and it surprised
me and I commend the film for that that
being said this movie just is not for me
and it's just not really the best movie
to go see in theaters I would say if you
are like eight years old I don't think
anyone watches me to take if you are
eight years old and you watch this movie
on TV you might really enjoy it with
your family uh but if you're older than
that I think it's it's just kind of
there it's an okay movie and it's not as
bad as it looks and that's nice to say
but for the most part it's just it's
it's okay it's it's on life of Timothy
green it's a boy who grew from the
garden it's starring Jennifer Garner I'm
gonna give the odd life of Timothy green
a C+ and as always guys if you like this
review you can subscribe to my channel
and get stuck my guys